hello and welcome to cloud on air the
live webinars from Google cloud we are
hosting these every Tuesday my name is
Chris Lattimer I'm a product manager
here at Google I focus on API is an API
management and I'm joined by my esteemed
colleague hi my name is Scott Gallo I'm
a software engineer and I've been
working on the adapter that you're about
to see for mixer and today we're gonna
be talking about the role of API
management and the sto service mesh so
let's start off by talking about what a
service mesh is and why we need one so
if you're like most companies you
probably have a lot of people thinking
that micro services are awesome you're
probably looking at ways to adopt micro
services and build a micro services
based architecture but why exactly do we
need micro services if you think about
the alternative what we typically call a
monolith there's a lot of good things
about a monolith for one thing it's
usually in one big codebase so if you're
gonna work on a monolith it's really
easy we just have to clone one repo
we're usually working in a single
project we're usually building just one
thing running one thing it's really easy
to get started with a monolith usually
where monoliths break down is that they
grow and they keep growing and growing
and growing and not just from a code
base standpoint but also the number of
people that are working on Model S and
so when that happens we start to run
into challenges usually we start to have
to coordinate our releases and when we
look at really big companies that are
building these monoliths these
mission-critical monoliths it's not
uncommon that they can only release you
know two or three times a year and so
when we're trying to get increased
agility from our organization it's
really hard to do with the monolith
especially as they start to grow and
it's around that point that most
organizations start to look
micro-services right so micro services
have a number of advantages they address
a lot of the concerns that we have with
monoliths so instead of having one big
codebase we can decompose a monolith
into a number of micro services these
micro services usually have some kind of
bounded context we have a dedicated team
that works on these they're
independently deployable and dependently
scalable and when we start to look at
orchestrating all of these micro
services to work together to form a
system we usually think of this or refer
to this as a service mesh
now this isn't to say that micro
services are a perfect solution if you
look at what happens as micro services
grow and your service match starts to
grow you'll run into a number of
challenges so when we try to look at
things like dependencies across services
this is fairly easy when you have a
small set of micro services as they
start to increase figuring out what
depends on something else is tricky one
of the things that we like about micro
services is that they are independently
deployable so if you have a change to a
micro service you can deploy that
without necessarily waiting for
everything else to be deployed but
that's not always the case you may have
situations where you have dependencies
on these services so if you have a
change that's breaking you want to
understand who's braking and you want to
have a way to manage those dependencies
so that you can minimize the impact the
other thing is with the monolith if we
all of a sudden have a problem may be an
exception happens we've got a stack
trace that tells us the entire
application where did this problem
originally from when you're looking
across the mesh of micro services that's
a trickier problem to solve to be able
to pinpoint exactly where the problem is
occurring and so as you start to look at
those those are some hard problems to
solve and you might be thinking to
yourself well gosh our micro service is
that great and the good news is just
about every technology that we've ever
used has some type of challenge
associated with it and micro services
are no different and when that happens
what we tend to do is we look to build
out tools and frameworks and platforms
that are going to solve those hard
problems for us so that we can focus on
the business value and the business
logic that we want to build and we want
to run in our micro services and that's
really what SDO is trying to try to do
for us and there there are so let me
talk a little bit about what this teo is
first so it's an open source platform
for solving these problems that we just
described it's a collaboration between
Google IBM lyft Cisco many other
companies are all working together to
build out this platform and the platform
really has three main areas that it
looks to address so the first is around
observability so if you think about
micro services we're building these in
different languages we might be building
micro services and go
and Java C++ Python whatever language
you may prefer but all those
micro-services we want to be able to
look at a common set of data we want to
be able to look across those services
and understand how are they performing
are we seeing an uptick in airs across
these services how much traffic is
flowing through these micro services and
we don't necessarily want to build that
into each in every micro service
individually what we would rather do is
delegate that down to a platform in this
case sto provides that capability for
you to solve that problem the other
challenge is around agility so again I
mentioned if all of a sudden we're
deploying a new version of a micro
service we don't necessarily want to
break everything that depends on that
and so in order to accomplish that we
might want to do things like like roll
out a canary version so we want to see
if we actually break something maybe
send a small percentage of traffic to it
we want to handle routing to the
appropriate service of the appropriate
version of the service again that
becomes very easy with Sto and then of
course just like anything else we
different technical standpoint security
is going to be a paramount concern and
we want to be able to apply security
very easily so the way that we
accomplish this in sto is with three
main control plane components so we've
got pilot pilots gonna be responsible
for all the configuration of this do so
when you're ready to deploy a microt
service and apply policies to it you're
going to interact with pilot now those
policies are going to be enforced by
something called mixer so normally we
want to apply things like like traffic
management or rate limiting we want to
put in place security checks the way
that those security checks are defined
is in policies and the way they're
enforced is with a component called
mixer and we'll talk a little bit more
about mixer coming up and then finally
we have Citadel so Citadel is what's
going to handle all of the network
security for us it's going to provide
services service authentication
authorization using mutual TLS so what
exactly can we do with with the security
aspects of this deal well the first
thing is we're going to be able to use
mutual TLS to identify the service and
the service consumer so because it's
mutual TLS we're going to have assurance
that we know exactly which service is
making a call in
and we're also going to be able to apply
authorization rules so we're gonna be
able to say is this service allowed to
call another service in our mesh and we
can even go one degree finer as well we
can actually have fine-grained rules
around that service the service
communication so maybe I have an invoice
service in that invoice service has two
types of consumers may be one of those
consumers is allowed to have a read-only
access maybe one's allowed to have full
access and with Sto were able to provide
the capabilities for applying those
rules now those rules are actually
enforced by mixer so with mixer what we
can do is we can say we've got Citadel
which has provided a secure channel of
communication across all of these these
different service interactions but we
may also have policy based enforcement
that we want to apply as well mixer is
the extensible platform that allows us
to enforce these policies so mixer has a
number of integrations that are
pre-built so we've got integrations with
Apogee with stackdriver with Zipkin with
many others and so it's very easy for us
to take a micro service and quickly
apply these policies quickly apply
transport level security across all the
communication and all of that is
configured using pilot so pilot is going
to be the mechanism that we interact
with that's going to take all of those
components and allow us to push a
configuration across across everything
and even though these may sound like
there's a lot of things going on we've
made it extremely easy for you to use
with this do all you need to do is write
a few snippets of yamo to describe your
service to describe the policies that
you want to enforce on to the services
push those in and all of a sudden SPO
takes care of the rest so you've now got
a feeling for what sto is and all the
components let's take a look now at how
it actually works in practice okay Wow
as you can see it's do does a lot for
you right I'm not gonna have time to go
through all of that because we're going
to want to get to API management in a
bit but I do want to show you a little
bit about
out what sto does and this this is the
book info app this is the architecture
for it
it's a simple app that comes with this
do as you can see it just has a page
that you can hit it has a login thing
and a bunch of different versions of a
review service right and you know when
the when the features that you talked
about with the micro services is all of
these are running in different
environments different languages so we
have a Python Java node Ruby all working
together for this this one app so let's
let's get in let me show you so what I
did here is I just installed sto on
kubernetes book info 8 and a gateway
sorry gateway so that you can access it
and I'm just going to show you what that
page looks like so this is the the
details page for one of the books the
comedy of errors right and as I refresh
what you'll see is different versions of
the review service now normally you
might go in and and as you said you
might have a canary or something like I
want to take version 1 and then apply
version 2 to like 20% of traffic or
maybe just the tester and access that
and so I can do all that but what I want
to show you is some of the cool stuff
that happens after the fact in the
telemetry and we have all these plugins
that are available for eager service
graph graph on ax Prometheus and I just
wanted to show you for example a service
graph so when as when I was hitting
refresh on on that page earlier this was
actually being generated this actually
shows you how your request is traveling
through the system and which versions
you're hitting you can see review
version 3 ratings version 1 things like
that yeah this is like what we were
talking earlier about the problems with
micro services and really understanding
what's dependent on what this just makes
it crystal clear exactly what what's
being used so you can see exactly what's
going on
in addition let me show you the Jager UI
you can actually see traces so if I take
and pick one of my requests I can
actually see the breakdown of how long
it took at each service and which
service forwarded on to the next yeah I
mean you can imagine if you're if you're
managing a set of these micro services
and you get a call from the help desk
that says hey this application is
starting to run really slow rather than
have to go in and try to deep you know
drill into logs and look at individual
calls this just makes it extremely
evident exactly what I'm chopping right
it's all right here and it's and it's
live so as soon as I send a new request
you would see that request as well in
addition of course you have some of the
cool Griffin oh stuff there's a number
of different dashboards that come with
obviously you can set up your own I like
to see you know like the workloads and
how they're responding across time and
you can see obviously I haven't made a
lot of requests here but just the
requests that I have made are showing up
right here for you sorry I mean this
would be great if you're somebody in
operations and you want to be able to
look and see if things are getting out
of the normal right healthy bear ice
again just makes it the nice thing about
this is it really addresses the
individual personas and the individual
roles that you have another organization
and what everybody needs to see
specifically exactly exactly and then
see we also have prometheus that that
also it shows you another view of this
information and you can see either a
graph or a console of exactly how the
requests came through and all the the
log details on that and again this is
all being generated in real time all
through that a Dabra you didn't go in
and write code in each individual
microservice everything that you see
here this is all coming just from the
fact that you plugged your services and
just you just the fact that you deployed
on this do absolutely ok so I'm going to
hand it back to you then great thanks a
lot so that's that's really service
management so you can see there's a lot
of advantages that come with sto out of
the box so we talked a little bit
earlier about some of the challenges we
have with monoliths in terms of it
you saw Scott show three different
versions of that service that was alive
at the same time now
he was refreshing and we were sending
those sort of arbitrarily in a normal
type of real-world situation what we
would want to do is we want to look at
that service graph we would want to
understand where my next version caused
some breaking changes and be more
deliberate in terms of how we roll those
out and how we're handling those
dependencies but right away you can see
there's a lot of benefits that come from
asiye just right out of the box but now
what if we want to take one of those
services that we build out in this DL
and we want to externalize that we want
to turn that into and more traditional
API maybe we want to expose it within
our organization to partners or we want
to put it out for anyone on the Internet
generally that's where we start to think
about API management coming into play
and we start to think of these as more
traditional API management problems to
solve and so let's talk a little bit
about API management and what it is and
what people are typically looking at
when they want to implement an API
management solution usually we're
thinking about tools for humans that are
going to be building applications using
these api's and it'll often that starts
with an API catalog of some sort we want
to make it very easy for people to look
into the catalog browse through search
through find the api's that are
available then look at documentation for
those api's to understand how it works
we usually want to have some type of
self-service mechanism so that if you
decide this API is going to work in my
particular application I can just simply
sign up for an API key or both
credentials and I can start to build my
application on top of those we also want
to think about features that are
applicable for an API product manager so
a lot of times with api's we have
different types of consumers that are
going to be using these we may have a
public program where we want to have a
silver gold and platinum tier of our
product maybe we want to monetize those
as well or maybe we just want to
productize those for different types of
internal and external consumers maybe we
have applications that we built which
are maybe our call center app maybe our
mobile app and we know that they're
going to have higher traffic than some
others we want to prioritize that
traffic we want to give them higher
entitlements to use and then again from
a product minute
standpoint often we want to look at how
our api's are actually behaving how
they're being used if we roll out a new
feature in the API but we want to see
your people actually using this in
applications and we want to be able to
take advantage of the visibility that
API management gives us now
traditionally the way that we tie in our
runtime aspects of api's from the
configuration aspects of api is with
something called an api gateway and
usually these are a centralized
enforcement point where we might put
these in our DMZ we might put these the
appropriate point in our network to
provide centralized control over things
like access control we might want to
have a authorial adacia nor job
validation we might want to put in place
throttling or threat protection edge
caching or more complex transformations
and mediations and these work great for
traditional api's the question we get
quite a bit is that well what if I'm in
a service mesh and I already have a
sidecar proxy that's running it's
already intercepting my traffic I don't
necessarily want to put another
component into my architecture and have
an additional network hop so how can we
avoid that so the good news is we built
API management for sto and what this
allows you to do is it allows you to
take all of the runtime capabilities of
Sto and apply policies from API
management now one of the next questions
we often get is well do I need API
management for all my services and in
general no you want to pick and choose
where it's appropriate so with a lot of
services you may have things that are
completely internal to your service
match they may only be called by other
services you never want to take those
capabilities open those up and expose
for people to consume and other times
you'll have things that are very
applicable that you know you can put
into mobile apps into other applications
and get all kinds of business value out
of those and those are the places where
we want to enforce API management rules
so how are these different because a lot
of times we'll look at this and say well
it seems like sto has a gateway
Appaji has a gateway sto has some things
for authentication and so does Apogee so
what are the different times and
approaches that we might take in one
situation versus another so one of the
biggest things that you'll see right off
the bat is that with API management
we're generally
thinking about http-based api's things
that are very specifically at that l7
layer of the network with sto we have
more control over what we can actually
what we can actually manage so we can do
things that at the l3 l4 layers as well
as the l solid layers from an
authentication authorization perspective
sto is very much interested in service
identity so we talked about Citadel we
talked about the ability to use em TLS
and certificate based authentication and
authorization approaches with API
management we're generally thinking
about things like oh ah and we're
thinking about jobs and we're thinking
about API keys that applications are
going to use so we can identify those
apps when a call comes in will also see
differences in terms of things like rate
limiting so from a service perspective
where you usually want to put at a
service level rules about how this
service is going to be limits around how
the service can be used how often it can
be called and rate limits from an API
perspective are often going to be more
around the use case that's happening so
again we'll see a lot of companies that
are opening up api's to the public and
they want to have different tiers and
different monetization packages that go
along with those those are really much
more of an API management problem then
we want to think about API management
solutions versus service management and
then from a portal perspective again
from the main consumer in service
management is going to be other services
whereas from an API management
perspective we're thinking about people
that are building the apps we're really
thinking about the humans that are out
there that are building apps that are
going to use these api's and for that
reason we tend to think of a portal as a
more foundational component of API
management so what does this actually
look like when we think about Apogee API
management in is do so if we started off
with just a pure service management
approach we've got the components we've
talked about before we've got in a
sidecar proxy that we've deployed along
with our micro service we've configured
pilot to send the necessary
configuration and the mixer and into the
proxy and we've configured mixer to be
able to enforce those now if we want to
apply API management rules the good news
is
mixer is extensible so mixer gives us
all the mechanisms that we need to apply
API management rules so if you start
looking at some of those capabilities we
discussed things like API key or
validation validation performing some
type of mediation or transformation
quotas and analytic pipelines we can
actually avoid having a separate API
gateway and we can tie into the
mechanisms the Sto gives us using mixer
and so what we've done is we built an
adapter when I say we I really mean you
have built an adapter that let's just
apply all of those capabilities using
the apogee platform and so again as
interesting as this picture is I think
is much more interesting if we turn it
back over to Scott and actually take a
look at how this works in Brite yeah
yeah no actually I think that was a
fascinating picture it's actually a good
one if you want to go back and
understand how all these pieces fit
together well we're gonna go back to our
little book info application here and
the one thing that was missing before is
we had an app right and people could
could go and look at look up this book
information but now if I wanted to write
my own app on top of that how would I do
that
or if I'm if I'm the the book info
provider how do I give that to other
developers and the way we're going to do
that is we're just going to expose for
our example here the details information
as an API right so first off I get over
here and show you what we're going to do
first is expose a virtual service to
allow the details information to be
provided to the outside world outside of
instant outside of the mesh in the
service mesh and a virtual service is
really just a set of endpoints that that
you want to expose right and the default
service shows you can see here that you
have a product page login logout things
like that all that is part of the
application and what we're doing is
adding this little blips sorry adding
this little bit here at the
bottom which it says I want to expose a
details directly out right and this this
will actually go expose this virtual
service here and and all we have to do
is apply that using the the cube the
cube control so it's a kubernetes so so
basically what you're doing here is
you're telling sto I've got a I've got a
new API a virtual service here the pass
that is going to expect that you should
be able to apply policies on these
here's the fix that you should look at
and now you're gonna use cube cut' all
to actually send that configuration in
yes yes so you can see I've created
configured the book info right and then
we should be able to actually do a curl
on that and this is live by the way this
is this is not made up this is an
existing system I installed just like
it's the same book info system that I
showed you in the beginning and now
we're actually getting a JSON payload
back from my details page ok so now this
call actually went right to that virtual
service let me just configure it in is
to you right right
the service was already there I just
changed the routing so I could get to it
so we showed that in the pre and the
previous example you had this all set
all right this is the book in Pro app
and in fact if you want to will show
later you can go into sto dot IO and
this is a sample app that comes with the
platform right right so so now we have
the API right the the problem of course
is nobody knows about it it's it's
unprotected nobody knows how to use it
no that's good right that's just an
accident waiting to happen
so what we want to do is start managing
it through Apogee and what I'm going to
do here is so this this first a little
bit is a one-time configuration it just
tells sto about Apogee that the adapter
exists right so this is the mechanism we
talked about the fact that mixer is
extensible and say write that extension
and this is you telling us to you now
you want to use that extension right in
your mash so the first part here just
declares that there is an Apogee adapter
you
in the configuration the next one
defines the template for my analytics
because I want to pull information out
of this do and give it to Apogee so that
it also can report on this information
there's an instance configuration for
that this just tells us which attributes
of out of s do we want and then a
template for authorization that tells us
which attributes were looking for for
example an API key so that right there
that's the hook in that we have from
sort of the sto configuration and to
what Apogee is expecting so right right
apply this is part of what you might
call installation is to set this up
right the next thing we want to do is we
define an Apogee handler so now this
tells us this tells sto the adapter that
we just created how to connect to an
Apogee environment so you have an
organization and environment set up as
part of Apogee that actually tells this
tells your system how to do the
authentication and authorization quota
and things like that and this will
actually connect that created and then
finally we're gonna define a rule and
what the rule does is tells us tells sto
alright in these under these conditions
apply Apogee management and in this case
we're just it's a simple rule we're
gonna say when the destination services
details so it won't affect the rest but
when its details we're gonna send
authors they send authorization to
Apogee and send the analytic strategy so
you so you took the handler so that's
basically the request Handler and you're
telling us to do that this is how we're
gonna handle requests and then you
configure this a rule that says here are
the rules that we actually want to apply
right when we see a request matching
these be the specific condition right so
now at this point Apogee is in control
of that API so if we attempt to access
that we're going to hit the
authentication authorization quota
management and it's going to report on
that
and let's actually first off let's look
at what Apogee actually looks like and
and how we define that information here
as you can see this I've set up this
already so this is this is a product
that I've set up for developers to be
able to access and you can see here that
when you set it up you can set up
multiple environments and apply them as
you wish now a mixer only a attaches to
one of the environments so you can have
two versions of it or whatever you want
to do but you have that access you have
a key approval which will see when you
get to the portal yep a quota I set up a
quota five requests every minute that's
pretty low but we want to see how that
works right it's easier than showing you
a thousand like that exactly exactly
like a thousand times so we talked about
product ization so this is the mechanism
and Apogee we have right right and this
this also is live so as if I change it
it will be automatically updated in this
do right and you also have resource
paths and and down here you can see it's
a little bit small perhaps but you can
see that the service that I want to
connect to is listed there so I say that
I'm going to details default that
service cluster local that's just a coup
banette ease DNS and right where you can
find right right and it tells tells us
right there okay so let's go back here
and now that we've protected it we can't
get to it right so nobody nobody can get
to it without an API key anymore well so
how do we get the API key well I
mentioned the development pull developer
portal sorry so let's take a look at
that now I've already created a portal
and basically it just involves selecting
a few things selecting which products
you want to make available right and
I've logged in so I want you to see the
app so I created an app and said okay I
want to access the details page and my
app then says ok I have access here to
this product the book info details and I
have
key here and I have a secret so normally
I would take this key and copy it I've
already done that for us here and you
can see here's the key that we got and
I'm going to run the same command only
this time I'm going to pass it an API
key I know I have access again right so
now we've protected it which is great
and and it's an authorization is done
there too as far as like path access and
things like that I I allowed any path so
alright so now developers can hit our
API that's cool so what do we know about
them well now we can go back into Apogee
and we can look at developer engagement
and we can see that actually this is my
developer here it's a little small again
sorry yeah and we can see other things
like proxy performance and we can narrow
that down to just the the details page
and see that information and this isn't
an either/or proposition we can still
get do analytics on absolutely
absolutely a hundred percent very cool
yeah all right so let's get back let's
we we have the quota so here I set up a
little script it's going to hit it a
bunch of times really quick and there we
go all right so for this key this my
developer can only access at five times
a minute and each one each developer has
that same quota so what have we done
we've exposed the API published it to
the portal required a key to access it
we allow developers to register and get
those keys and we can set you know per
developer quota limits right so one more
thing I think we have time I just want
to show you that we can also do all op
right so here's an OAuth definition and
I'm not going to spend too much time on
it we you can specify an issuer and and
Searle and things like that
I'm going to apply that now I need to
generate a token part of that is I need
to not only have the key
but now I need to have the secret right
so you're put the secret in here and
this is just a little script that
generates a token and does the call and
you can see I'm just doing the curl
again this time with a bearer token so
you can see it token was generated and
something didn't work let me just try it
again yeah all right something it
doesn't like something I don't think
we're pretty good we've got all the way
through the demo there's been only one
hiccup we don't have time to do see bug
that regardless all right so let's let's
get back to wrapping up here so so
hopefully after this demo you can see
you got a lot of great capabilities that
come with ISTE oh it's going to solve a
lot of those core microservices problems
that you're going to run into as you try
to scale microservices and then
inevitably when you need to take one of
those micro services and you need to
expose that out as an API and you
traditional API management we've made it
very easy with API management for sto to
tying into all the capabilities of
appaji and build that right into the
platform so you have really have a
seamless developer experience that you
can take advantage of now I'm sure many
of you are probably wondering what next
this was great content but I'd like to
dive a little bit deeper so the good
news is we've got a great write-up for
you on the Apogee API management for sto
plugin that Scott just went through and
don't worry if you don't have time to
write down these links we're gonna put
those into the QA you can grab them from
there if you're building micro services
we also have an e-book that we've taken
all the lessons learned from our
customers and we've built out a great
resource for you to learn about what's
worked and what's not worked at our
customers as they're building out micro
services and then if you want to get
hands-on with the platform if you're not
an existing Apogee customer we have a
free version for you you can sign up
today for an evaluation you can start
playing around with it you can run
through the same example that Scott just
did and if you are an existing Apogee
customer the documentation is alive you
can go out there today you can learn
more about API management for SEO using
the apogee platform and with that we're
going to take a quick break so in
roughly a minute
we're gonna come back and we're going to
have live QA stick around and we'll be
right back
you
so great looks like we have some
questions so let's go ahead and address
those now I'll start with the first one
so it's got all direct this one at use
so this sto work for workloads running
on VMs if you ask can you please explain
how yeah well absolutely it does it's
designed to be independent of kubernetes
mostly there's what what you would end
up doing is through the mesh expansion
abilities you can actually run the the
proxy next to any container anywhere
right it just has to have access back to
the main sto the pilot has to be able to
configure it and has to be able to
access you know the mixer and the other
components of the system so so yeah
absolutely if you're running most of
your clothes on bm's you're not on
kubernetes yet sto is still extremely
valuable for you so let's jump to the
second one what is the difference
between analytics provided by Apogee and
the one provided by Sto so again I think
we actually saw a quite a bit of this
and right in the demo so some of the
things that we saw in there where sto
has a so the way sto analytics work are
really with that telemetry adapter and
you can take that data that's coming in
to sto and you can put it wherever you'd
like so we've used that same mechanism
and apogee to take the data that's
coming in and feed it into a purchase
analytics system but we also saw jogger
we saw Prometheus right and depending on
your role in the organization this new
gives you a way to get access and
visibility into the information you need
so if you're an API product manager and
you want to look at the analytics that
are coming into Apogee you've got all
the dashboards that are in Apogee if you
are a mesh administrator and you're
looking for ways to track the
dependencies across all of your mesh
we've got that in there as well with
this do and then of course we saw from
the the grow fauna of dashboards that
you looked at a way for operations
people to get a very quick way to
determine like what traffic's coming in
if things are suddenly getting out of
the normal range vectors right and I
think one of the key details is Apogee
provides a higher level view right it's
it's more tied to your developers and
and the and
around them how how the product is being
used and utilized so let's jump to the
to the next one I'll let you handle this
one as well Scott so what kind of data
related to Apogee has cashed at envoy
and then we could expand this to be not
just envoy but maybe you know anywhere
right yeah yeah exactly so so we don't
really cache data at envoy now when when
you the only exception is is if you
install the the auto op bit right it the
envoy actually does get the public
certificate for validating your tokens
but that's not even Apogee specific
that's that's just how how it works how
is deal works we do cache some data in
mixer we cache information about the API
keys the the jot tokens for the their
lifetime and some product information
and this is so that we can respond
immediately and and not get in the way
of requests traveling through this do we
don't want to go up to the apogee server
for every request and you can understand
that would add a lot of unwanted latency
definitely so let's talk about the next
one here what are the best ways to
secure communication between Apogee and
the sto ingress and I'm gonna say this
is pretty similar to just like anything
else within within Apogee where we need
to secure the communication between
Apogee and the back end right we're
gonna use standard techniques we can use
things like IP whitelisting we can use
mutual TLS one-way TLS all the things
that you've come to know and love in
terms of network security that have been
around for a long time are still
applicable here right
and today's we're all right yeah out of
the box you know it's it's of course on
using HTTPS right for communication it
actually does communicate with
authentication its own authentication I
showed you in the handler the
authentication that you give to sto to
the adapter so that it it can indicate
with Apogee on there as well great so
the last one that we have here so you
said the feature is GA
you help us understand how to start
using this feature is it priced
separately yes so as we showed in the
the resources for this briefly and again
the links should be in the QA we've got
a lot of we've got documentation we've
got a great write-up in terms of how to
get started using this feature if you
want to get started with just sto sto
dot IO is the website that you want to
go to that's where you can get started
with sort of just the purest EO
framework and start working with that
and then again from the the Apogee API
management for sto we've got the
documentation that's in the in the Q&A
so you can read through understand how
it works and then we've got everything
that you need to get started now if you
are an Apogee customer current Apogee
Enterprise customer and you're
interested and sort of in the pricing
this isn't priced separately what we're
doing is we're if you're using our
Apogee edged micro gateway today it's
very similar we're essentially charging
based on the number of API calls that
are coming through so typically you have
an entitlement of several hundred
million calls per quarter or several
several hundred million calls per or
billion calls per year
sorry tens of billion calls per year and
so what we're doing is we're essentially
calculating those API calls that are
coming in through the adopter forest do
at a three-to-one ratio similar to what
we do for the micro gateway and it looks
like that is our last question so thank
you all so much for attending this today
we've enjoyed speaking with you enjoyed
your questions and please stay tuned for
the next session we have managing Chrome
browser updates in the enterprise thank
you thank you
you